you
all right I think I'm gonna jump into
one here what's going on how about an
hourly bullet arena that's currently
being played there are only four minutes
in but let's jump into this one so a
slight late joint if you'd like to jump
in there's 24 players already an hourly
bullet arena I just linked it so we have
some ground to make up
okay no three check this is regular
chess I need to win upon one strike at
this guy he's weak he's six ready to
take now I'm off upon and I think I just
want to open up the diagonal towards
their king and get my rook on f2 it's
running mate I missed it back to
tournament - I'm in 10th okay quick W
fours a few fours up there Homer wells
okay they're moving very fast that's why
I went for this now we got their queen
back determine guy watch out those early
moves are key you know those first few
seconds if you get the sense hey you
know they're there there may be a little
primo
you know like this guy if he darted out
a move really maybe he's gonna do it
no he was all onto it a back to back
here imagine that a back to back quick
kill all right this isn't so bad
well you could get away with nearly
anything huh in bullet 95 his looking
juicing
Oh Oh big trouble I keep the pin let's
make them work a little a little bit
harder I can do that
now we're gonna take and let's keep this
pin
you bugger its undermined this um look
here huh
I'm not really getting at them actually
this is a main threat huh damn bishop
here Oh
bishop there let's get a check
you got some windmill action where's the
mate um oh my goodness I'm scared oh man
nine seconds there's that move oh my god
what a disaster what a disaster and I
got a time burning stuff oh they missed
that trying to deflect me give me the
King position man how are we doing on
the clock
this could just capture that bishop you
idiots they're down on time I don't know
I don't know what to think I just don't
know what to think had just some juicy
windmills and everything you know you
want to try to find the killer the
killer move and then you know what to
say just suppositions are so appealing
you know you just want to find the
knockout but I just couldn't and I had
to eat up a ton of time it cost me
can I say it cost me some time and it's
fighting for my life
watch out for the minority attack and a
weak bond here I want my night on c4 how
does he get there
it's a big mystery might have to throw
him in the corner one day might happen
soon the night in the corner that's a
wonderful plan isn't it
put the knight in the corner I wasn't
joking wasn't joking
I want my night on b6 right here the
night here
don't play rook a6 don't be a pest here
we go I don't see four and everything is
beautiful there we go the B pun they get
undermine that what's b4 huh no I got
him so now he's passed let's just take
him out he's too tricky that's also with
an eye on the clock that I did that
didn't have any time time burners
there we go back to tournament where do
we stand 12s tied we got 12 16 change 57
players are now in this one okay let's
see who we get have four games in this
is our sixth game okay let's go with the
Kings side fiend kiddo
and we'll sneak that move in there give
the knight a boot if he goes to g-form
high up d6 they're giving me the dark
square bishop I get to develop with
tempo probably move the knight where to
now let's go here I'm on g7 at the end
oh they missed I was on their Queen they
resigned back to term in sixteen sixteen
twelve twelve okay yeah that one um I
had ideas of just I don't know it was
going to simplify I was going to look to
play with a four and there Brooks
weren't connected when I played a four
they'd have to make some concession give
up the c-4 square all right all right
I'm doing something other than this is
silly next that's enough
mm-hmm let's go here fishing pole you
haven't done that in a while
Oh slanted board and fishing pole nests
awful man awful careful rook be very
careful very careful Oh watch out for
mr. Fudd he's around here we go
that's just open stuff up I did this to
stop the night move here soon to have
every piece doing some damage here we go
hmm oh that scared me
could you tell could you tell that that
scared me can't survive this
two wild pigs feel like I don't need my
queen at this point pawn mate got it
back to tournament all the pieces were
surrounding 20 2016 he finished just now
did he not it doesn't show him in a game
probably getting paired up so big game
coming up yeah this was his game it's
finished so we should be paired up we
are paired up with the top dog didn't I
say I was gonna wasn't going to play the
Sicilian all right this is a good move
to get in with tempo let's kick him
around where's he gonna go let's get
that pawn sack in there
I gotta go on castled now I'm gonna go
Queen side h3 I'll take here first and
then they're gonna have some Swiss
cheese I want to get into f4 what's
wrong with d4 gouf d4 is beautiful you
should have been there yesterday get out
of there I want d4
Point f3 how they defend that can't okay
that's a check I'd like to get a night
move with Chuck oh this can't survive
this can you
let's first insert this move I could go
here bishop check okay how is this being
how do you survive this f4 is hit a
million times I have 92 and night g3
yeah this is a big trouble very big
trouble that got this let's try it once
more let's do it the other night you
know wasn't the most convincing was it
no oh well fortunately they don't have
enough time but they do have that mouth
being sneaky there they chewed up a lot
of time and they had to didn't finish
that how I should have thought ah yeah
that was tough as soon as I got in the
d3 move well actually you know maybe I
could even go one step back because when
d5 hit with tempo d4 was gonna hit with
tempo and then d3 so there was a pretty
serious threat early on in that one the
d5 strike at the sea floor Bishop so
let's see Bishop g4 runs into a trick
it'll still run into a trick if they go
here and they miss that 95 they're
picking up that guy they resigned that's
an early resign I don't think they
should have resigned that early 28 2016
11 and change 69 players in just under
11
how do we have next Ricky remedy is in
this one again Wow
alright alright let's let's harass this
night this is a week in square keep that
pawn h4 if they Castle a Queen h4 pretty
killer pretty killer b5 I have that
covered
okay yeah let's jump right in
they could have played Bishop f3 but I
probably would have had some
compensation I don't want to help their
Queen develop let's go Queen side yeah
this is a good spot for my bishop um ok
it's weakening weakening here but I
should be alright
let's expand my bishop is enormous
I have 93 you've had 93 for some time
okay good block checks with Queen here
let's keep the night out could have also
captured him huh Bishop takes Knight
yeah I want to keep Queens on no I'm
gonna have the safer king or at least
I'm doing it as if I I'm going to soon
have the safer King let's just go here
and I will take and play this I'm gonna
play King there watch out for Queen here
Queen take C - isn't this close to me
feels like it let's give a check take
care of its check take there and let's
just make it really simple booth I
should have exchanged Queens first get
rid the night no crazy stalemates it's
Chuck that's me okay it was closer on
the clock but I still had some pressure
in that game 232 22 2010 9 yeah that's
you don't see that too often uh that was
2 game to the same opponent twice within
three games
farmville ok he was in the candidates
players list for that cyma I didn't get
paired up though paired up now royal
apes' stop Knight d4 and Bishop g4 and
we're gonna make use of f1 before I
Castle ok might want to do that
it's weakening to the light squares but
I don't know if I want to deal with ya
let's just keep that out h5 no I didn't
want to do that
oops didn't want to do that oh boy and
this is such a weak diagonal so scary
yepper queens looking to play on it ya
didn't want to do that
no good on
and bring the other night there about
ahead of myself that Bishop is just too
too good I got it I got to do something
about that
I got exchanged light-square bishop s'
can't even do this now my Knights pinned
ooh
they dropped the bishop it's helpful on
this pawn not anymore
um why aren't you moving
wow that move took you forever man
forever Oh playing this terrible I was
helpful time is a problem don't you dare
move your darks for Bishop whatever you
do don't move your darks or a bishop on
the Queen let's defend the pawn not sure
what that's doing
you
I can't I can't talk if I'm down on time
don't be expecting less they're naughty
always shoot there's no audio issue I
gotta concentrate it sound like I'm
getting mad at you for no reason I'm not
really getting mad at you that's not
what's going on I just try to explain
myself just get caught up at the moment
you know what I mean get caught up at
the moment
make legal moves that's all that's
running through my mind when I'm not
talking like that oh it's going to my
mind is finding legal moves make legal
moves keep an eye on the clock and then
rinse and repeat it's the same thing
over and over finally gonna keep an eye
on the clock keep going move forward
grab a rook
it's intense chess is an intense game
okay put your rook to use there you go
smash through on f6 we have less than
five I have a 12 minute lead 12 minute
li don't expect things to make sense I
have a 12 point lead call it 14 point
lead
78 players now 4:30 left here's the
number 2 guy
all right let's throw Knight f6 Adam and
c5
uh-huh you went away voluntarily or are
you as scared of b5 what were you scared
of that guy's pin there's no f3 no I
like the light square bishop exchange
standing opposite the king
give me the bishop there he is a knight
on c4 would be fantastic no trades I
looked to one day kick a knight from
that square maybe this and that light
square weaknesses Forks although there
is Knight h5 I want to be a bit careful
about that g6 is conservative let's go
here and here keep pressure on the
knight sneak into the light squares it's
where they're weak on push I take on e3
I could take this and now this is a
threat forks
week these guys are split that's the
heart of the structure that was
eliminated let's get this guy working
first they can't go here just yet I'm on
c3 let's scoop him up
they're nights out of play that f4
Knight is not doing anything he'll be
put to you soon Knight h3 I guess is the
only way to defend but I have g5 maybe
f5 soon with g4 don't want to drop this
pawn though I guess here these guys are
linked together there they're down on
time a big time edge in that one forty
four twenty eight twenty six twenty six
two and a half left
225 okay let's do something different
how about some Grand Prix attack with
Bishop c4 instead of b5 there is no
knight on c6 so let's stop a quick b5
strike let's get out of a pin drift over
towards h4
hmm I guess they could take I have to go
back to f2 mmm it's gonna be a little
bit awkward but I could soon kick a
night out of the g4 square
let's rule it out all together mmm
Brooke a8 might be a good move okay
let's get out of this pin now how am i
reconnected I'm looking at c3 next and
f5 let's do c3 first night b5 okay let's
cover him oh okay let's see if I could
get some compensation on these dark
squares that's the piece they gave up
let's break down here I also have this
poet's check let's do that let's take
care yeah there should definitely be
some compensation okay so I stole the
dark square bishop hand a 10 second lead
let's give this check up upon I lost
track
let's take yeah here I'm taking it the
Queen I want to get this guy next hmm
I nearly mouse looked out let's back him
up get out of the line of fire running
mate I think they're covers it but I get
a pawn at least think tank uh-oh are
they resigned yeah that's gonna do it
that's gonna be the last game 15 seconds
left only forty eight thirty thirty
twenty six twenty a couple early a
couple quick wins early I made up for
this late entry okay so finished with
forty eight thirty to thirty twenty six
eighty five players and oh and I see
Popovic they're probably joined a bit
too late only getting in five games
let's see everybody else page two three
four five six seven eight nine
okay to the eighty four of you that took
part in this hourly bullet arena good
games Oh
you